[Music]
florida governor ron desantis recently
signed
senate bill 90 into law the law is
designed to limit voting access
in florida in a myriad of ways including
limiting the use of drop boxes adding
new id
requirements and making absentee voting
more difficult
all steps specifically designed to
disenfranchise black voters
and desantis was so excited about the
bill he signed it live on the air during
an episode of fox and friends
you're doing the same thing what's going
to be different about florida's
election in 2022 what are you about to
sign
so right now i have what we think is the
the strongest election integrity
measures in the country i'm actually
going to sign it right here it's going
to take effect
so there you go bill is signed
look at this he's doing something
crooked and he's proud of it
he's doing something evil and he's proud
of it this man is lying and he's proud
of it
he thought it would make for a good
photo opportunity
well we agree in fact we actually got
this photo framed because
i have the perfect spot for it the wall
of
politicians who showed their whole ass
this wall is truly filled with [ __ ]
and they're all
on display like this one of rutherford b
hayes getting sworn in after agreeing to
the compromise of 1877
when democrats and republicans came
together to dismantle reconstruction
pave the way for jim crow and in the
process show their whole ass
or this one of senator theodore bilbo
seen here
sweating bullets as he tries to deny to
his colleagues that
he incited violence against african
americans during the election campaign
of 1946 and
if you look closely you can see his
whole ass
or this one of senator strom thurmond
who proudly blocked the civil rights
act of 1957 using the longest filibuster
in history
and you know what else he also used his
whole ass
now let's take a look at this one
president bill clinton
he was signing the 1994 crime bill
written by then-senator joe biden ass
out
that accelerated mass incarceration
rates
he later apologized for showing his
whole ass
or this one isn't this strong
thurman again no could have fooled me
it's mitch mcconnell in 2016 he's
announcing that the senate would not be
considering president obama's nominee
for the supreme court
during an election year and even though
we only see him from the front
somehow the photographer managed to
capture his whole
ass or this one of senator josh hawley
showing his whole ass
to a mob of traitors on january 6th and
they loved it and
they all showed their asses right back
at him oh
look here's a spot oh let's see
yeah perfect so governor desantis
congratulations you've made it to the
wall of politicians who showed their
whole ass
and guess what once you're up there you
never come down
actually we're burning this thing down
right after the show stick around
[Music]
you